This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Hi, everyone. Hello, thank you. I'm great. Sarah and David Risa recently bought a place outside of Washington, DC. They sound excited because this is the first time they're hosting both their families. We are making today a vegetable frittata with tomato, basil and goat cheese. We've got home fries, We've got regular waffles.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。大家好。大家好，谢谢你们。我很好。萨拉和大卫·里萨最近在华盛顿特区郊外买了一处房子。听起来他们很兴奋，因为这是他们第一次同时接待双方的家人。我们今天要做的是一道带有西红柿、罗勒和山羊奶酪的蔬菜烘蛋。我们有炸薯饼，还有普通华夫饼。
Sara and David wanted to start a new tradition. Cook brunch with ingredients from their home garden. The home fries have rose married from our garden and the potato has basil from our garden. This is Sara's way of going back to her family's roots. She remembers her mother doing the very same thing. I remember growing up my mom had a garden and she would always come back with like these tiny little tomatoes and be like I provided for my family look family. I grew this and we're like, yeah, that's the smallest tomato ever But there's something about being able to grow stuff and being able to Give it to people that you love that's pretty exciting. So yeah, my grandmother would always say that this is Sarah's brothers Ah, the sharing food is important, but I'd say the most important part
萨拉和大卫想开启一项新的传统。用他们自家菜园的食材烹制早午餐。炸薯饼里有我们菜园里的迷迭香，土豆里有我们菜园里的罗勒。这是萨拉回归家族之根的方式。她记得她的母亲也做过完全一样的事情。我记得小时候我妈妈有一个菜园，她总是会带回诸如此类的小西红柿，然后说：“我为我的家人付出了，看呐，家人。我种了这个。”然后我们会说：“没错，这是有史以来最小的西红柿。”但能够种植东西，并把它送给你爱的人，这种感觉非常奇妙。所以，是的，我奶奶总是会说——这是萨拉的兄弟。分享食物很重要，但我认为最重要的一部分
is being around the table. But food was the lurch to get everyone out. Yeah, exactly. We kept us there. Yes, exactly. Food brought us together, but it was the company and the conversation. Today on Hidden Brain,
是围坐在餐桌旁。但食物是把大家吸引出来的诱饵。对，没错。让我们留了下来。没错，是的。食物把我们凝聚在一起，但真正让我们留下的，是陪伴和交谈。今天在《隐藏的大脑》中，
the profound role that food plays in our lives. Food is not just nutrition that goes in your mouth, or even pleasant sensations that go with it. It connects to your whole life. We look at the culture and psychology that determine what we eat, what we spit out, and when we come back for more. Paul Rosen has been studying the psychology and culture of food for more than 40 years. He works at the University of Pennsylvania. Early in his career, Paul found himself pondering a question that few of us might think to ask, why do so many people across the world enjoy
食物在我们生活中扮演的深远角色。食物不仅是进入口中的营养，甚至不仅仅是随之而来的愉悦感。它与你的整个人生息息相关。我们来探讨决定我们吃什么、吐什么以及什么时候想再来一份的文化与心理学。保罗·罗森研究食物的心理学和文化已有40多年。他在宾夕法尼亚大学工作。在职业生涯的早期，保罗发现自己陷入了一个我们大多数人可能都不会去思考的问题：为什么世界上有那么多人喜欢
the hot, stinging pain of chili peppers? This question took Paul to a small village in Mexico where chili peppers were as common as salt and pepper in the United States. They don't think their food tastes good without it, and the little kids don't like it. So something happens somewhere between two and five years of age. At the meals where everybody adult is eating the hot pepper and the older children are and they're all enjoying it and a little kid is thinking it's terrible. And after a while some magic occurs and the little kids like it. So I thought, well, we had there a number of possible accounts.
辣椒那种火辣、刺痛的痛感？这个问题把保罗带到了墨西哥的一个小村庄，在那里，辣椒就像美国的盐和胡椒一样普遍。他们觉得没有辣椒的食物不好吃，而小孩子并不喜欢它。所以在两到五岁之间的某个时候，事情发生了变化。在所有大人都在吃辣椒、大龄儿童也在吃并且都很享受的饭桌上，一个小孩子却觉得这太糟糕了。过了一段时间，某种神奇的事情发生了，小孩子也开始喜欢它了。所以我想，嗯，我们当时有几种可能的解释。
Some accounts involve something fundamentally biological. And presumably the biological explanation would be if you start eating it long enough, you're eventually just going to like it for biological reasons. Yes, that's right. The brain compensates for all sorts of things. We adapt to things. This is a case of more than adaptation, where you're turning something that's negative into something positive.
有些解释涉及到一些根本性的生物学因素。据推测，生物学上的解释是，如果你吃得够久，出于生物学的原因，你最终自然会喜欢上它。是的，没错。大脑会为各种事情进行补偿。我们会适应各种事物。这是一个超越适应的例子，你把一个消极的东西变成了一个积极的东西。
I mean, to me, that's an amazing thing that we can start with something that's innately negative and make it really positive. So I said, let's take a look at the animals in the village, because the dogs and the pigs eat Mexican food. They're eating tacos and hot sauce and beans and all of that's love. So I went around the village and I first asked people, do you have any dogs or pigs that like hot pepper? And they said, what are you crazy?
我的意思是，对我来说，这是一件了不起的事情，我们可以从一个天生消极的东西开始，把它变成非常积极的东西。所以我说，让我们来看看村子里的动物，因为这里的狗和猪也吃墨西哥食物。它们吃塔可饼、辣酱、豆子等等。所以我走遍了村子，首先问人们：“你们有没有喜欢辣椒的狗或猪？”他们说：“你疯了吗？”
I said, well, yeah, I mean they eat it and they said, that's ridiculous. I said, would you mind if I give the dogs a little piece of cracker with some hot sauce on it and without and see what they choose? So they said, go ahead. And so I did would go around the village with pigs and dogs. I put a one cracker in front of them with hot pepper sauce and another without and I'd see what they did. And it turns out that none of them ate the hot pepper first. They all ate the one without pepper because they're hungry, but their first choice
我说：“好吧，我是说它们确实吃。”他们说：“这太荒谬了。”我说：“如果我给狗一小块抹了辣酱的饼干，另一块不抹，看看它们怎么选，你们介意吗？”他们说：“去吧。”于是我就拿着饼干在村子里找猪和狗。我在它们面前放了一块加辣酱的饼干和一块不加的饼干，看它们会怎么做。结果它们谁也没有先吃带辣椒的。它们都先吃了不带辣椒的那块，因为它们饿了，但它们的第一选择
was the one without hot pepper. So that I couldn't find an animal in the village that did what everyone over five years old in humans did, which was the gobbler stuff out on preferred. So that suggested to me that it seems to be uniquely human. And so this is not just a question of people getting used to it and getting to like it, because the dogs and pigs are eating the garbage. The garbage is laced with chili peppers. If that was the case, that would be true for the animals as well. So what was happening in the humans, in the human brain, if you will, that allowed five-year-old
是不带辣椒的那块。所以我无法在村里找到一只动物，能像人类中所有五岁以上的人那样，狼吞虎咽地首选那些食物。这向我表明，这似乎是人类独有的。所以这不仅仅是一个人们习惯并开始喜欢它的问题，因为狗和猪也在吃垃圾。垃圾里就掺杂着辣椒。如果是那样的话，动物也应该如此。那么，人类的大脑里到底发生了什么，使得五岁的
children to fall in love with chili peppers and kept their canine cousins from liking it? Well, that's indeed exactly the question. We don't know how this happens, but we do know that where it happens is at the meals where the kids are eating with their parents and their older siblings, and they keep eating it because the social pressure to eat it. Now the animals keep eating it too because they're hungry, so it can't be just that they keep eating it. So it's really, to me, a miracle.
儿童爱上了辣椒，而它们的犬科表亲却不喜欢它？嗯，这确实正是问题所在。我们不知道这是怎么发生的，但我们确实知道，它发生的地方是在孩子们和父母以及年长兄弟姐妹一起吃饭的饭桌上，他们不断地吃是因为有进食的社会压力。现在动物们也在继续吃，因为它们饿了，所以不可能只是因为它们一直在吃。所以对我来说，这真的是一个奇迹。
And what I realized is that it's a miracle that takes place in humans all over the world, not just about hot pepper. It's also about liking coffee, which is bitter, and people don't like it originally, and they like it. And it goes outside the food domain. People like to go on roller coasters. Now, a roller coaster is a very negative experience the first time you have it, right? You think you're crashing to death. And your heart is pounding and yet people pay to do this.
我意识到，这是一个发生在全世界人类身上的奇迹，不仅仅关于辣椒。它也关乎喜欢咖啡，咖啡是苦的，人们一开始并不喜欢，后来却喜欢上了。而且它超越了食物的范畴。人们喜欢坐过山车。现在，第一次坐过山车是非常糟糕的体验，对吧？你觉得自己要坠毁身亡了。你的心在狂跳，然而人们却花钱去体验这个。
Can you imagine a dog paying to go on a roller coaster? I mean, you know, it just won't happen. So we found that there's a whole range of things in which humans enjoy what is originally negative and they come to enjoy it as positive. This includes the fatigue of running, it includes said movies, it includes being afraid in horror movies. This seems to be only humans. So our thought, and it's only a thought, is that what humans are enjoying is the very fact that their body thinks that something is bad,
你能想象一只狗花钱去坐过山车吗？我是说，你知道的，这根本不会发生。所以我们发现，人类有一系列的事情，他们会享受那些最初是负面的东西，并最终将它们当作积极的体验来享受。这包括跑步的疲劳，包括悲伤的电影，包括在恐怖电影中感到害怕。这似乎只有人类才会这样。所以我们的想法——这只是一个想法——是人类所享受的，正是他们的身体认为某事是不好的这一事实，
but they know it's okay. We call it benign masochism. You have the special ability to appreciate the fact that they know that something that their body is saying is bad is actually good. And we have evidence for that. So, for example, for chili pepper, the favorite degree of hotness is just below the level of unbearable pain. They're pushing as far as they can to get their body to really screen, get this out of here and yet know that it's okay. So it seems to be a very general feature of humans which we tapped into by asking water a couple of billion people
但他们知道其实没事。我们称之为良性 masochism（良性自虐）。你有一种特殊的能力，能够欣赏这样一件事：他们知道身体在说不好的东西实际上是好的。我们有证据证明这一点。例如，对于辣椒，人们最喜欢的辣度刚好在无法忍受的痛感之下。他们尽可能地把身体逼到极限，让身体真正尖叫着“把这东西拿开”，但同时又知道其实没关系。所以这似乎是人类的一个非常普遍的特征，我们通过询问几十亿人
like hot pepper. So in some ways the theory is that you start out not liking it and then social pressure if you will convinces you to try it and then you try it often enough that your body learns to adapt to it a little bit, but then eventually you start to like it for actually a slightly different reason. You're no longer liking it just because of the pure pressure or the social interactions you're liking it because it gives you a sense that you're coming close to the edge of something thrilling. Is that the argument?
为什么喜欢辣椒来发现了这一点。所以在某种程度上，这个理论是这样的：你一开始并不喜欢它，然后社会压力说服你去尝试它，接着你经常尝试，以至于你的身体学会了一点点适应它，但最终你开始喜欢它，其实是出于一个稍微不同的原因。你不再仅仅因为同辈压力或社交互动而喜欢它，你喜欢它是因为它给你带来了一种接近某种惊险边缘的感觉。是这个论点吗？
Yes, there's something thrilling that is not threatening. Right. So, for example, if something is threatening, you don't get to like it. Like, people don't get to like serious pain. Right. It has to have something of the sense of it's not really threatening. And it even becomes funny. So, in the case of disgust, people don't like disgusting things, right?
是的，有一种不具有威胁性的惊险感。对。所以，例如，如果某事具有威胁性，你不会喜欢上它。就像人们不会喜欢严重的疼痛一样。对。它必须具备某种“并非真的具有威胁性”的感觉。它甚至变得很有趣。所以在厌恶的情况下，人们不喜欢令人作呕的东西，对吧？
But they make exceptions. They eat smelly cheese, and they come to like that smell in the context of the cheese, even though their body is saying, get this out of your mouth, it stinks. You once performed an experiment on yourself. You were with your wife, I believe, at a Korean restaurant in New York City. And you didn't interview with NPR back in 2015,
但他们有例外。他们吃臭奶酪，并且在奶酪的语境下开始喜欢那种气味，尽管他们的身体在说：把这东西从你嘴里拿开，它太臭了。你曾经在自己身上做过一个实验。我相信你当时和你的妻子在纽约市的一家韩国餐馆里。你在2015年接受了NPR的采访，
where you told the reporter that it was one of the hottest things you'd ever eaten. Tell me that story. Well, my wife at the time was a cookbook writer and she was very interested in cuisine. We went to a Korean restaurant in New York and the people around us, they were ordering some dish that we didn't recognize.
你在采访中告诉记者，那是你吃过最辣的东西之一。给我讲讲这个故事吧。嗯，我当时的妻子是一位食谱作家，她对烹饪非常感兴趣。我们在纽约去了一家韩国餐馆，我们周围的人正在点一些我们认不出来的菜。
So we said to the waiter, we would like that. And he says, you don't want that. I said, no, no, we said, we really like to try new foods. He says, you don't want to try that food. So this went on, and we won, of course. And he brought this dish, and it was unbearably hot. And we ate it because we were shamed into eating it by our own insistence that it was good.
于是我们对服务员说：“我们要那个。”他说：“你们不会想吃那个的。”我说：“不，不，我们真的很想尝试新的食物。”他说：“你们不想尝试那道菜。”这种情况持续了一会儿，当然，我们赢了。他端上了这道菜，辣得令人难以忍受。我们把它吃完了，因为我们出于对“食物很好”这一坚持的执念，硬着头皮把它吃下去了。
I have another story of a different sort. It also happened in New York, I had a colleague who had a dog and the dog liked to eat dog poop. So they were going to Washington Square Park and with the dog and the dog, we just hunt out a dog poop and eat it and it was just awful. You know, they hated it and the dog smelled it. So they went to a vet and the vet said, why don't you put hot pepper on the dog poop because dogs don't like hot pepper. So they go into Washington Square, I want you to get this image. Barbers holding the dog on a
我还有另一个不同类型的故事。它也发生在纽约，我有一个同事有一只狗，这只狗喜欢吃狗屎。所以他们和狗一起去华盛顿广场公园，然后这只狗就会去找狗屎吃，这太糟糕了。你知道的，他们讨厌这样，而且狗身上也有这种气味。于是他们去找兽医，兽医说：“你们为什么不在狗屎上撒点辣椒呢，因为狗不喜欢辣椒。”所以他们去了华盛顿广场，我想让你们脑补一下这个画面：丈夫手里牵着一条
leash and our husband goes with a shaker of hot pepper, finds a dog turn and seasons it in front of everybody with all this hot pepper, okay? And I mean the idea of someone seasoning a dog turn and seasons it in front of everybody with all this hot pepper. I mean the idea of someone seasoning a dog turn is really pretty good. And then they let the dog go and the dog ate it. And did the dog stop eating dog poop? No no because the dog like dog poop more than it does like the hotness. You know people will put up with pain to do something they really like, right? Just as Paul has shown that the sense of taste is shaped by the brain,
狗，妻子拿着一罐辣椒粉，找到一坨狗屎，在所有人面前用各种辣椒粉给它调味，好吧？我是说，有人给狗屎调味的这个想法真的很绝。然后他们放开狗，狗把那坨屎吃了。那狗停止吃狗屎了吗？没有，没有，因为狗比喜欢辣味更喜欢狗屎。你知道，人们为了做他们真正喜欢的事情会忍受痛苦，对吧？正如保罗所展示的那样，味觉是由大脑塑造的，
he's also done work that shows the same thing for appetite. In one study, he set a meal down before patients who had amnesia. The general view in most of the people who work on hunger is that hunger comes when your body reserves are low, or maybe your glucose is low, various hormones come out, and you feel this sensation of hunger and you eat until it disappears. Now there's some truth in that, of course, but there are many other higher order things. So for example, the cultural definition of what's a meal is very important.
他还做过研究表明食欲也是如此。在一项研究中，他在患有健忘症的病人面前摆好了一顿饭。大多数研究饥饿感的人的普遍观点是，当你身体的储备不足时，或者也许你的葡萄糖水平较低时，各种荷尔蒙就会分泌出来，你就会感到饥饿感，然后你一直吃，直到这种感觉消失。现在这其中当然有一定道理，但还有许多其他更高级别的因素。例如，对“什么是饭”的文化定义非常重要。
After you finish the meal and have dessert, you stop eating. So, to try to show this, we dealt with the two amnesic patients who were totally amnesic. They didn't remember anything that happened more than 30 seconds ago. But they were quite intact otherwise. So, we fed them lunch in a situation where they were in a room without a clock. And we said lunchtime, and it was lunchtime, and we brought them a favorite lunch of theirs. We'd asked them what their lunch was, and they, of course, ate it.
当你吃完饭并吃完甜点后，你就会停止进食。为了证明这一点，我们研究了两名完全失忆的健忘症患者。他们不记得30秒前发生的任何事情。但在其他方面他们相当健全。所以，我们在一个没有时钟的房间里给他们提供午餐。我们说是吃午餐的时间了，当时也确实是午餐时间，我们给他们端上了他们最喜欢的午餐。我们问过他们午餐想吃什么，他们当然都吃光了。
Then we took the plate away. There were no more signs that they'd eaten. And ten minutes later, we brought another lunch and said lunchtime, and they all ate it. Three times each. The second lunch completely. Then we took that away, we ate it 10 minutes and brought a third lunch. Each of these were full-size lunches.
然后我们把盘子收走。没有任何他们已经吃过饭的迹象。十分钟后，我们又端来一份午餐，说是午餐时间，他们全都吃光了。每人吃了三次。第二份午餐吃得精光。然后我们把它收走，过了10分钟又端上第三份午餐。这些全都是标准大小的午餐。
And most of the time they ate the third lunch, twice I think one of them said, I'm getting a little stuffed, meaning their stomach was really getting full. But the point was that they're eating, when you're served a meal, it looks palatable, you tend to eat it. I was on a plane once flying to Chicago at a three
而且大多数时候他们把第三份午餐也吃了，我想有两次其中一个人说：“我有点饱了”，意思是他们的胃真的快饱了。但重点是他们在进食，当你被端上一餐时，它看起来很好吃，你往往就会吃。我曾经有一次在下午三点坐飞机去芝加哥，
in the afternoon, they serve the full lunch. Now, everyone had eaten lunch already, but six out of the nine people who I could see, ate that lunch because it was lunch and it was food and it looked good, probably wasn't good if it was airplane food, but they ate it. So a lot of what we do is we eat when there's good food around
他们提供了一顿正餐。现在，每个人都已经吃过午饭了，但我能看到的九个人中有六个人吃那顿午餐，因为那是午餐，是食物，而且看起来不错——如果那是飞机餐的话可能算不上好——但他们还是吃了。所以我们的很多行为都是：周围有美食时我们就吃，
and when the situation is appropriate. Now if we had left their first lunch and they saw the plate in front of them with the pieces of chicken bone, they might have realized that I've just eaten. And when we give people, normal people, a second meal in the same way I just described, they don't say I'm not hungry.
而且当场景合适时我们就吃。现在，如果我们把他们第一顿饭的盘子留在那里，他们看到盘子里有鸡骨头，他们可能就会意识到我已经吃过了。当我们给正常人同样提供第二餐时，我刚才描述的那样，他们不会说我不饿。
They say I just ate. So it's fascinating because I think what you're saying really is that memory plays a huge role in whether we think we're hungry. Yes, being hungry is only one reason that we eat. So if you go for a full dinner, halfway through that dinner, you're not hungry anymore. But you're still eating the rest of the meal.
他们会说我刚刚吃过。所以这很迷人，因为我认为你所说的话实际上表明，记忆在我们是否认为自己饿了方面发挥了巨大的作用。是的，感到饥饿只是我们进食的原因之一。所以如果你去吃一顿丰盛的晚餐，吃到一半时，你就不再饿了。但你仍然在吃完剩下的饭菜。
That's right. So a hunger can't institute meals. The lack of it will probably discourage you from eating more, but there are other things that influence you too. When we come back, one of those things is the role that culture plays in our experience of food. We'll also look at how you can serve more memorable meals.
没错。所以饥饿不能主导进食。缺乏饥饿感可能会劝阻你吃更多，但还有其他事情也会影响你。当我们回来时，其中一件事就是文化在我们食物体验中所扮演的角色。我们还将探讨如何提供更令人难忘的餐食。
Stay with us. Some time ago, one of our producers attended a dinner for Ramadan and iftar at an apartment in Washington Washington DC. Ramadan is the ninth month of the Islamic calendar and commemorates the first revelation of the Quran to the Prophet Muhammad. Food plays an important role during Ramadan. For 30 days, Muslims like Esma Al Barudi fast from sunrise to sunset as a way to practice self-discipline and to reflect on that connection to their faith. So not being able to eat all day and then coming and having that meal makes you
请继续收听。不久前，我们的制作人之一在华盛顿特区的一间公寓里参加了一场斋月开斋晚宴。斋月是伊斯兰历的第九个月，旨在纪念《古兰经》首次降示给先知穆罕默德。食物在斋月期间扮演着重要的角色。在30天里，像埃斯玛·阿尔·巴鲁迪（Esma Al Barudi）这样的穆斯林从日出到日落禁食，以此作为练习自律和反思与信仰联系的一种方式。因此，一整天不能吃东西，然后来吃那顿饭，会让你对
grateful for what you have. By deliberately going without food, Tasnim al-Qaik says, hunger can make people mindful about the role that food plays in their lives. The Papa, he narrated, saying that you should fill your stomach with three things. One third for food, one third for drink, and one third for air. And so I'm always thinking about that, especially after a long day of fasting, because it's a natural instinct to just put three thirds full of food and keeping that in mind, constantly reminding myself to always leave room to properly breathe.
你所拥有的一切心怀感激。塔斯尼姆·阿尔·凯克（Tasnim al-Qaik）说，通过刻意不进食，饥饿可以让人对食物在他们生活中扮演的角色保持正念。先知曾传述说，你应该用三部分来填饱你的胃：三分之一留给食物，三分之一留给饮料，三分之一留给空气。所以我一直在思考这个问题，尤其是在经历了一整天的禁食之后，因为把胃塞满三分之三的食物是人类的自然本能，牢记这一点，不断提醒自己始终留出空间以便正常呼吸。
Breaking the fast comes with its own rituals. keeping that in mind, constantly reminding myself to always leave room to properly breathe. Breaking the fast comes with its own rituals. So it's a really, I think a communal experience. You break your fast almost every single night with friends and family and you go to the mosque afterwards. Many Muslims that iftar dinners aren't just breaking a fast. They're enacting and reinforcing their sense of identity. Ramadan illustrates the profound role that food plays in shaping our cultural behavior
开斋伴随着它自己的仪式。牢记这一点，不断提醒自己始终留出空间以便正常呼吸。开斋伴随着它自己的仪式。所以，我认为这确实是一种社区共享的体验。你几乎每天晚上都和朋友家人一起开斋，之后还会去清真寺。许多穆斯林认为，开斋饭不仅仅是打破斋戒。它们是在演绎和强化他们的身份认同感。斋月说明了食物在塑造我们的文化行为方面发挥的深远作用，
and how culture in turn can shape the way we think of food. And that's the case for Ahmed Assad. Food is just like the glue that holds a lot of cultures together. You know, when I'm like, I'm looking around the room right now and there are people from probably like seven or eight different countries. So it's one of those things that's like you appreciate other cultures and you appreciate I think the oneness of what we are and what all of that stands for as a whole. Psychologist Paul Rosen has spent many decades examining the interplay between food, identity, and culture.
以及文化反过来如何塑造我们对食物的看法。艾哈迈德·阿萨德（Ahmed Assad）就是这种情况。食物就像是把许多文化凝聚在一起的胶水。你知道，就像我，我现在环顾四周，房间里的人大概来自七八个不同的国家。所以这是那种让你欣赏其他文化的事物，我认为你也会欣赏我们作为一个整体以及这一切所代表的统一性。心理学家保罗·罗森花了数十年时间研究食物、身份认同和文化之间的相互作用。
Food is not just nutrition that goes in your mouth or even pleasant sensations that go with it. It connects to your whole life and it's really a very important part of performing your culture and experiencing your culture. When Paul asked people about their favourite meals, they certainly mentioned eating at great restaurants, But they also talk about meals with friends and family, like the one we just heard about. Here's a very common answer that's very short, for a home meal. Every Christmas Eve, my Italian grandfather and Greek grandmother would cook a meal, consisting of creamy carbonara with bacon pieces throughout, homemade spinach pie and sausage.
食物不仅是进入口中的营养，甚至不是随之而来的愉悦感。它与你的整个人生息息相关，而且它确实是展现你的文化和体验你文化的一个非常重要的部分。当保罗询问人们最喜欢的餐食时，他们肯定会提到在伟大的餐馆用餐，但他们也会谈论与朋友和家人的餐食，就像我们刚刚听到那样。这是一个非常常见且非常简短的回答，关于家常饭菜。每个平安夜，我的意大利祖父和希腊祖母都会做一顿饭，包括奶油培根意面、自制菠菜派和香肠。
It was always amazing. Now that's a lovely one, right? And it's not fancy, but you can see the emotion and the pleasure of it. And it's connected, of course, to the pleasure of family, not just to the pleasure of food. Yes, it's very social. Another one, the best meal I've ever had in my life
它总是那么美味。现在这是一个美好的回忆，对吧？它并不花哨，但你能看到其中的情感和快乐。当然，它与家庭的快乐息息相关，而不仅仅是食物的快乐。是的，这非常具有社交性。另一个回答，我一生中吃过最好的一顿饭
was when I got out of jail. Having been in jail for three years and eating prison food was horrible. When I got out, I got a hardy Frisco burger combo meal. That was the best burger in fries I've ever had. Okay, so that's, you know, it's a context. It's a release from bad eating. So the contrast is so important there. Contrast and context can also be important
是我出狱的时候。在监狱里待了三年，吃监狱里的食物太糟糕了。我出来后，吃了一个哈迪斯（Frisco）汉堡套餐。那是我吃过最好吃的汉堡和薯条。好吧，所以你知道，这是一个语境。这是对糟糕饮食的一种解脱。所以那里的对比非常重要。对比和语境在思考一顿单餐时也很重要。
when it comes to thinking about an individual meal. Consider the difference between a tapas-style meal and a meal that's built around one large entree. In both cases, you can fill up your stomach, but it turns out these have very different effects on your brain. As social scientists have found, most of us find it difficult to tell the difference between the tenth bite and the eleventh bite of the very same food. There's a whole line of modern decision research, most associated with Daniel Conneman, who
考虑一下小吃风格（Tapas）的餐食与围绕一道大主菜构建的餐食之间的区别。在这两种情况下，你都可以填饱肚子，但事实证明，它们对你的大脑有着截然不同的影响。正如社会科学家所发现的那样，我们大多数人很难分辨出完全相同的食物的第十口和第十一口有什么区别。有一整代现代决策研究，主要与丹尼尔·卡尼曼（Daniel Kahneman）相关——他因此获得了诺贝尔奖——还有阿莫斯·特沃斯基（Amos Tversky），他们表明，你知道，人们并不像你所期望的那样理性。
got a Nobel Prize for it, and Amos Torsky showing that, you know, people are not so rational as you might expect them to be. And one of the features of it is called duration neglect, which is people don't remember how long an experience is. They just remember the experience. So if you had a pain for 12 hours or a pain for one hour, two weeks later, what you remember is the experience of the pain, not how long it was. So this applied to food means that if you have the same food, a lot of the same food, it won't produce a very different
其中的一个特征被称为“持续时间忽视”，也就是说人们并不记得经历持续了多长时间。他们只记得这段经历。所以如果你疼痛了12小时或疼痛了1小时，两周后，你记住的是疼痛的体验，而不是它持续了多久。这应用到食物上意味着，如果你吃同样的食物，很多同样的食物，它不会产生与吃少量同样食物截然不同的记忆，因为这是吃食物的记忆。
memory from having a little of that same food, because it's the memory of eating the food. So this raises a very important question that Coniman originally brought up, which is, the distinction between your experience and your memory for the experience. Coniman and others have shown, we've done some work on this too,
这就引出了一个卡尼曼最初提出的非常重要的问题，即你的体验与你对体验的记忆之间的区别。卡尼曼和其他人已经证明，我们在这一方面也做了一些研究，
that the ending of an experience is particularly important. So when you remember something, you're more likely to remember the end of it. And also, by the way, to some extent, more likely to remember the beginning of it. And that would mean if you want to produce the best memory for food, you should put the best foods at the beginning and the end, whereas most people think the entree is the best, which is in the middle and is the least remembered.
一段经历的结尾部分尤为重要。所以当你回忆某事时，你更有可能记住它的结尾。顺便说一句，在某种程度上，你也更有可能记住它的开头。这意味着如果你想为食物产生最好的记忆，你应该把最好的食物放在开头和结尾，而大多数人认为主菜是最好的，主菜在中间，也是最不容易被记住的。
We had Danny Kahneman on Hidden Brain recently, and of course he talked about the peak and rule and also about the difference between the experiencing self and the remembering self. Yes. And one of the implications of this, as you point out, this difference between experiencing a meal and remembering a meal, is it points to the difference between people who go to restaurants and order their favorite dish every time, and people who go to a restaurant and order a new dish every time. How do these two strategies essentially catering to two different psychological impulses? Well, that's an issue that we have looked at.
我们最近邀请了丹尼尔·卡尼曼做客《隐藏的大脑》，当然他谈到了“峰终定律”，也谈到了体验自我与记忆自我的区别。是的。正如你所指出的，这种体验一餐与记忆一餐的区别，其含义之一就是它指出了去餐馆每次都点最喜欢的菜的人，与每次去餐馆都点新菜的人之间的区别。这两种策略本质上迎合了两种不同的心理冲动？嗯，这是我们研究过的一个问题。
And it's pretty clear, if you're going to order your favorite food, and you know you're going to order that before you go to the restaurant, there are actually three aspects. There's your anticipation. This comes from the economy, the anticipation, the experience, and the memory. Your anticipation of a meal is going to be higher if you order your favorite food because you know you're going to have something great, right? Whereas if you can order something new, it's not even clear what you can imagine because you don't know what it is. At the meal itself, you're probably going to enjoy your favorite dish more than I knew this
而且很明显，如果你要点你最喜欢的食物，并且你知道在去餐馆之前就会点那个，其实有三个方面。有你的预期。这来自经济学，预期、体验和记忆。如果你点你最喜欢的食物，你对一餐的预期会更高，因为你知道你会吃到很棒的东西，对吧？而如果你点一样新的东西，你甚至不清楚你能想象出什么，因为你不知道它是什么。在饭局本身，你可能比尝试新食物更喜欢你最喜欢的菜，
because it's one of their best dishes. You love it. There's a little risk in ordering something though. But if you order your favorite dish, you're not going to create a new memory. Whereas if you order a new food, you're going to create a new memory. We are looking at this, but we don't know yet for sure. If you're a person who generally values memories, then you're going to try to create more memories by creating new experiences. Whereas if you value anticipation and experience more, you will keep doing the same wonderful thing. So how you value anticipation, memory and experience, affects how you're going to choose what activities you do.
因为这是他们最好的菜之一。你很喜欢它。不过点新菜确实有一点风险。但如果你点你最喜欢的菜，你不会创造新的记忆。而如果你点新的食物，你会创造新的记忆。我们正在研究这一点，但我们还不能百分之百确定。如果你是一个通常重视记忆的人，那么你会试图通过创造新的体验来创造更多的记忆。而如果你更看重预期和体验，你就会一直做同一件美妙的事情。所以你如何看待预期、记忆和体验，会影响你如何选择你要做什么活动。
Let's just take an example. Massage. Okay, I like massage. I go once a month, I get a massage. It's pretty much the same. I can't tell you last month's massage was exactly this. So I'm going for the anticipation and the experience, which is very positive. I don't really create much memory from this. And I do it, and I like it. But it's very different from the way I eat, where I'm always trying to say, I want to enrich my mental menu listing, my life experience of food. But people differ on this. We've been interested in trying to see if people
我们举个例子。按摩。好吧，我喜欢按摩。我一个月去一次，我做一次按摩。基本上都差不多。我不能告诉你上个月的按摩具体是怎样的。所以我追求的是预期和体验，这非常积极。我并没有从中创造出多少记忆。我做了，我很喜欢它。但这与我的饮食方式截然不同，我总是试图说：我想丰富我的心理菜单列表，丰富我食物的人生体验。但人们对此看法不一。我们一直有兴趣看看人们
are consistently different. We don't know yet. Think of a seven day Caribbean vacation at a resort. Almost nothing happens, right? You're feeling good. It's sun is good. You go in the water, it's nice. But there's no, if people say,
是否始终存在差异。我们还不知道。想象一下在度假村进行为期七天的加勒比海度假。几乎什么都没发生，对吧？你感觉很好。阳光很好。你去水里，感觉很棒。但没有，如果人们说，
tell me about your vacation, it's going to be a very short Thing right so there's two kinds of vacations what those that are Really high on experience and vacations that will give you a lot of experience But there'll also be some hardship you'll get tired something may not work Something might be closed when you thought it was open. All kinds of things can happen. So it won't be a totally positive experience, but it will be a bunch of good memories. You've thought a lot about the differences between the American attitude toward food and the French attitude toward food.
跟我讲讲你的假期，那将是一个非常简短的事情，对吧？所以有两种假期：一种是体验度非常高的假期，还有一种会给你带来很多体验的假期，但其中也会伴随一些艰难险阻：你会感到疲倦，某些东西可能无法正常运作，当你以为开门时某个地方可能关闭了。各种事情都有可能发生。所以它不会是一次完全积极的体验，但它会留下一堆美好的回忆。你深入思考过美国人对待食物的态度与法国人对待食物的态度之间的差异。
And you say that the French are more focused on what happens in the mouth, and Americans are often more focused by what happens in the bloodstream. I want to play you a short movie clip that illustrates this idea. Wow! If it isn't diner girl, what can I get you guys? What can I get here that has no sugar, no carbs, and is fat free? Water! Water!
你说法国人更关注嘴里发生的事情，而美国人往往更关注血液中发生的事情。我想放一段简短的电影剪辑来说明这个想法。哇！这不是快餐女孩吗，我能给你们拿点什么？这里有什么没有糖、没有碳水化合物而且零脂肪的？水！水！
Was that the first time I saw that movie? So that was from the movie A Cinderella Story Paul, and I'm wondering if you can just talk a little bit about this. The American attitude toward food versus the French attitude toward food. I go to France to fair them out. They seem to be enjoying their food more than we were. And interestingly enough, they're marginally healthier than we are. I mean, it's not a big difference, but they live a little longer, and they have less heart disease.
那是我第一次看那部电影吗？那是电影《灰姑娘的故事》，保罗，我想知道你是否可以简单谈谈这个。美国人对待食物的态度与法国人对待食物的态度。我去法国是为了品尝美食。他们似乎比我们更享受他们的食物。有趣的是，他们比我们稍微健康一点。我的意思是，这并不是一个巨大的差异，但他们寿命稍微长一点，心脏病发作得也更少。
And yet they eat a diet that's higher in animal fat than we do. It's okay if we're worrying about food and the consequence of that is that we're going to live longer. But we seem to be worrying about food and not living longer. So that seems like a bad exchange. So we started a study of how French and Americans differ in the way they eat. And it's basically got two parts to it. One is how they think about food, and the other is how their food world is set up. The French think about food as an oral experience.
然而他们的饮食中动物脂肪含量比我们高。如果我们担心食物，而其结果是我们能活得更久，那倒也罢了。但我们似乎既在担心食物，又没有活得更久。所以这似乎是一个糟糕的交易。于是我们开始研究法国人和美国人在饮食方式上有何不同。它基本上分为两部分。一部分是他们如何看待食物，另一部分是他们的食物世界是如何构建的。法国人将食物视为一种口腔体验。
They think about eating as something that is giving them pleasure. They don't tend to think about what's going into their bloodstream, how much sugar is in their animal fat. So they're getting more pleasure out of food because they're not worrying about it. So for example, if we ask French, when you think of heavy cream, do you think of whipped or unhealthy?
他们认为吃东西是一件能带给他们快乐的事情。他们往往不会去想什么东西进入了他们的血液，他们的动物脂肪里有多少糖。所以他们从食物中获得了更多的快乐，因为他们并不为此担忧。例如，如果我们问法国人，当你想到浓奶油时，你会想到打发奶油还是不健康的？
They will say usually whipped, and Americans will say unhealthy. Now it's the same thing, but they're thinking about it as an experience, and we're thinking about it more as a health event. And in some ways, that actually might be a good thing, right? Because presumably, when you take more pleasure in food, you're focused on it, you're not necessarily just focused on getting stuff in your mouth or focusing on nutrition. The French, for example, seem
他们通常会说打发奶油，而美国人会说不健康。现在这是同一回事，但他们把它当成一种体验来思考，而我们更多地把它当作一种健康事件来思考。在某些方面，这实际上可能是一件好事，对吧？因为据推测，当你从食物中获得更多快乐时，你会专注于它，而不一定只是专注于把东西塞进嘴里或专注于营养。例如，法国人似乎
to pay more attention to portion control than Americans, except that I don't know if they're thinking about this as control. They're thinking about this as in the enjoyment of food, and once I'm done enjoying this bite, I'm done with it. Well, they eat more slowly, first of all. So, they have more mouth experience because they don't swallow as quickly. They savor the food. So, I mean, if you have a chocolate bar, you can bolt it down in a couple of minutes so you can make a 10 or 15-minute experience out of it. And they're more inclined to the latter. We actually were able to measure how in McDonald's in Paris, how long people sat, and ate
比美国人更注重分量控制，只是我不知道他们是否将此视为一种控制。他们将其视为对食物的享受，一旦我享受完了这一口，我就结束了。嗯，首先他们吃得更慢。所以，他们有更多的口腔体验，因为他们吞咽得没有那么快。他们细细品味食物。所以，我的意思是，如果你有一块巧克力，你可以在几分钟内把它狼吞虎咽地吃完，或者你可以把它变成一个10到15分钟的体验。他们更倾向于后者。我们实际上能够测量在巴黎的麦当劳里，人们坐着吃的时间
compared to the McDonald's in the United States. Okay? And we made sure they were French people in McDonald's. They were talking French. The French people sitting in McDonald's sit there for longer than the American people sitting in McDonald's. So they're eating more slowly, they're talking more, you know, they're not just bolting down food.
与美国的麦当劳相比是怎样的。好吧？我们确保了麦当劳里坐着的是法国人。他们在说法语。坐在麦当劳里的法国人比坐在麦当劳里的美国人坐的时间更长。所以他们吃得更慢，他们聊得更多，你知道的，他们不只是狼吞虎咽地吃食物。
Food is not fuel. Americans often, not always, treat food as fuel. Whereas the French think about it not as a fueling, but as an event and experience. Now, in the food world, the big difference between the French and Americans is portion size. French traditionally serve smaller portions. If you look at a French cookbook,
食物不是燃料。美国人经常——并非总是——把食物当成燃料。而法国人则不认为它是燃料，而是把它当作一个事件和体验。现在，在食物世界里，法国人和美国人之间最大的区别在于分量大小。法国人传统上提供较小的分量。如果你看一本法国食谱，
the amount of meat for four people per person is less than an American cookbook. In McDonald's and France, the portions are smaller. Now, if you remember our discussion of the fact that you eat what's in front of you, if it's pleasant, the amnesic basins, the French put less food in front of you, and so they're eating less and enjoying it more. And that seems to me to be a good formula. Now, they have other features of it. The French meal is a much more elaborate event. People don't get up, especially at home. They don't get up in the middle of the meal and just leave
每个人四人份的肉量比美国食谱要少。在法国的麦当劳里，分量也更小。现在，如果你还记得我们关于“有什么在你面前你就吃什么——如果它令人愉快的话”（健忘症病人的例子）的讨论，法国人放在你面前的食物更少，所以他们吃得更少，却享受得更多。在我看来，这似乎是一个很好的公式。现在，他们还有其他特点。法国人的大餐是一项更加精致的活动。人们不会站起来，特别是在家里。他们不会在饭局中途离开
the table. Everybody eats the same thing. So it's a social event. So I would say the French deal with food well in the face of the modern world where there's so much good food around that we can easily stuff ourselves and eat everything under the sun. They are, they have managed to have a tradition which keeps it moderate and very pleasant. Paul Rosen has been studying the psychology and culture of food for over 40 years. He's currently at the University of Pennsylvania. Paul, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It's been a pleasure. This episode was produced by Thomas Liu and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parth Shah, Raina Cohen, and Laura Correll.
餐桌。每个人都吃一样的东西。所以这是一场社交活动。所以我想说，在现代世界面前，当有如此多的美食让我们很容易暴饮暴食并吃光天下所有东西时，法国人很好地应对了食物。他们成功地保持了一种保持适度且非常愉快的传统。保罗·罗森研究食物的心理学和文化已有40多年。他目前在宾夕法尼亚大学工作。保罗，谢谢你今天做客《隐藏的大脑》。这真是个荣幸。本集由托马斯·刘（Thomas Liu）制作，塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）剪辑。我们的团队包括珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、帕斯·沙阿（Parth Shah）、雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）和劳拉·科雷尔（Laura Correll）。
Armies are set to march on their stomachs. So too, it turns turns out our podcast teams are unsung heroes this week on Marco Matire, Janice McLean and Jeff Dewey's at NPR's cafeteria soundbites. On days you hear a pep in my voice, it's probably because of one of Jeff's omelets. Thank you Marco, Janice and Jeff and all of your colleagues. I'm Shankar Vidantam and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
军队靠胃行军。事实证明，本周我们的播客团队也是无名英雄，感谢NPR员工餐厅的马尔科·马蒂尔（Marco Matire）、珍妮斯·麦克莱恩（Janis McLean）和杰夫·杜伊（Jeff Dewey）提供的声音片段。在你们听到我声音中充满活力日子里，很可能是因为杰夫做的煎蛋之一。谢谢马尔科、珍妮斯、杰夫以及你们所有的同事。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这里是NPR。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。